you remember that orange guy with the
funny hair donald trump and he was
always talking about mexico and a border
and all that stuff well now biden who
used to call him racist is sort of doing
a lot of things or wants to do a lot of
things uh that trump was doing we've got
some info here from the blaze the biden
administration has reached a deal this
week with the mexican government to
relaunch the trump era remain in mexico
program the program officially known as
migrant protection protocols was
implemented in 2019 under trump and
requires migrants seeking asylum in the
u.s to stay in mexico while they wait
for their u.s court hearings by
establishing the program trump aimed to
prevent migrants traveling to the
southern border through mexico from
disappearing before their court hearings
and thus avoiding potential deportation
i mean that sounds pretty same to me and
yet of course it was called racist about
two years ago now it's being ushered in
by the biden administration which by the
way i don't know if you guys saw this
but like an hour ago
uh fauci called it the wuhan virus that
was something trump was always called
racist for too yeah he actually called
it the wuhan virus i just saw it this
morning oh my gosh liz let me throw to
you on this one first i mean we should
just sort of move past the hypocrisy
right like that's not the surprising
part here sane policy is that the
surprising part
well listen don't give the biden
administration more credit than they
deserve they haven't come to their
senses they're not reimplementing this
policy because it makes sense they're
doing so because a court is making them
a court is forcing them to and the court
even said that they have to implement
this policy again in good faith meaning
they can't try to get around it here but
i mean this policy is a good policy it
makes sense and i'll tell you why it
makes sense it makes sense because if we
have all of these migrants who are
essentially falsely claiming asylum just
because they want to be released into
the united states um we have to ask okay
well how many of them show up for their
court dates after they have been you
know detained by the border patrol and
then released into the united states and
given a court date told to come back to
have their asylum claim adjudicated how
many of them actually come back well
there was um one particular judge who
said that over 90 percent of the
migrants that she gave court dates to
did not show up for their hearing well
no kidding that's human nature i mean
dave would you show back up i probably
wouldn't be honest in this situation i
wouldn't if i'm being honest they're not
so of course then this is this is just a
soft form of amnesty this is a way of
allowing migrants regardless of whether
their asylum claims are legitimate to
just you know fade into the shadows into
the united states of course the biden
administration didn't want to do this
but the thing is without this policy
what happens is what's happening at the
border right now a travesty i mean the
biden administration's policies on
immigration are anti-woman they're
anti-child and they're anti-immigrant
let and that's not even taking into
account the fact that it's dangerous for
our national security and a burden on
welfare one in three women and children
are sexually assaulted on their way to
cross the border after they cross the
border while still in these cartel
trafficking houses it is anti-immigrant
anti-woman and anti-child to put a
policy in place knowing that it will
lead to the bodily harm of these people
just so that the cartels and the coyotes
can make a buck off of it by the way
it's also basically pro covid because
fauci was asked this week about you know
vaccines for people on airplanes coming
into the country and masks and all that
he's like yeah that's all good and then
they asked him about you know people
crossing the southern border illegally
he's like well that's something else i
mean it's just so bananas josh bananas
is not true by the way what he said
it's not true what fauci said fauci said
that there are some people that are
getting tested it is not a widespread
policy you can ask any border patrol
agent any ice agent this is not a
widespread thing they are not testing on
any kind of large scale bases no you can
just see the video that they only show
you on fox actually with just thousands
of people and they're not social
distancing either uh josh i suppose i
suppose you're not surprised by any of
this no i mean look we all remember the
videos from del rio texas which of
course was like the big hot topic of the
day just like a month and a half two
months ago or so here i mean the body
administration has they've been
disastrous on a lot of issues obviously
i mean afghanistan the withdrawal there
was particularly egregious i would say
but i i'm holding aside like perhaps the
afghanistan kind of crap show really
immigration and the board in particular
has been the one area where i think they
have consistently and repeatedly errored
most egregiously here and this is
totally right to mention that they're
only doing this on a
literally due to a a judicial decree and
they from from a very good judge by the
way uh judge kasmir and amarillo texas i
was very i'd probably say i was very
briefly colleagues with him before he
was tapped for the band she's a he's
he's a wonderful conservative so he did
the right thing here of course but you
know i i've actually talked over the
years with a lot of kind of doj folks
both while i was serving in the trump
administration and vote and afterwards
they literally unanimously have told me
that of all the various policies that
the trump administration put into place
mpp was by far the most effective at
actually stemming the tide of legal
immigration for the extremely common
sense logical reason that is exactly
what liz said which is if you get past
the border we have this ridiculous catch
and release policy going back to the
obama administration when jay johnson
was secretary of homeland security and
when you're releasing to the interior as
liz said of course you're not gonna show
up this is just such common sense so
look i mean i i guess we could say good
for the blind administration on this i
mean again like they're literally just
doing it at the force of like a judicial
gun i guess in theory they could like
choose to defy the court order so good
for them for not defying this completely
sane and proper court order but look
the situation on the border is egregious
for all the parties involved like liz
said it's not just the ranchers it's not
just the people living on the border
it's terrible for them too obviously but
the cartels we're talking here about
about the transnational cartels is the
sinaloa folks like that operating in
northern mexico we are talking about the
most vicious non-state actors in the
entire western hemisphere like these
people are brutal so we don't want to
empower them at all we should be
defanging them at any and all
possibilities and mpp is a very very
simple and straightforward way to do
that
so jana says the person here that works
for really the only cable news network
that's covering this at all and then got
banned at some point i think fox even
had helicopters up there and drones that
then were told they couldn't be up there
do you sense we have any real idea of
the numbers of people that have come in
in the last year whether they have
coveted or not where they are whether
they brought kids whether they're
getting welfare etc etc
i think you know the answer that it's
absolutely we're not we're not getting
those numbers at all and listen i'm
canadian and by
by birth i have dual citizenship my
father was american uh i came to the
land of opportunity and i understand
what it's like to want to come to
america and make a life for yourself
because this is the greatest country in
the world uh and i still had a mound of
paperwork to fill out uh to get to get
into this wonderful country so i
understand why these people want to come
here but you have to do it the right way
you have to
you